[Musica]
[Applauso]
Voi credete nel potere della
mente nelle vostre idee nei vostri
pensieri quelli che la notte non vi
fanno dormire perché vi tengono ATT a
sogni così grandi da sembrare
impossibili Io sì ma lasciate che vi
spieghi sono sempre stata una
sognatrice avevo 6 anni quando si piantò
nella mia mente il desiderio così grande
di viaggiare scoprire Nuovi Orizzonti
culture terre straniere tra i banchi di
scuola guardavo fuori dalla finestra e
pensavo che non ci fosse nulla di più
bello che vivere una vita ricca di
avventure il perché non chiedetemelo
ognuno viene al mondo con un sogno
diverso e questo aimè era proprio il
mio Peccato che fosse un sogno molto
grande bene Al di là della mia portata
sono nata e cresciuta in un piccolo
paesino nella provincia di Rimini non
proprio adatto a coltivare grandi
sogni Inoltre la vita non era proprio
stata tanto tenera con me nonho mai
fatto fatto un viaggio una vacanza né
tantomeno un weekend in montagna i miei
genitori insieme non li ricordo nemmeno
e in questo contesto da piccola ho
sofferto parecchio domandandomi a lungo
se un'altra vita non fosse proprio
possibile Poi però accadde qualcosa di
inaspettato Perché prima o poi nella
vita succede sempre qualcosa qualcosa di
meraviglioso era una mattina di
primavera avevo 19 anni e frequent Avo
l'ultimo anno del liceo quando mia madre
venne da me tra qualche mese
traslocherà che fare perché questa casa
non ci sarà più
bom mi sentì morire Mi C'è voluto un po'
di tempo per comprendere quello che che
stava accadendo Poi però ho
realizzato Mia madre si era innamorata
di un uomo il che era
meraviglioso il punto era che lui abita
in Sicilia a 1200 km di distanza dal
luogo in cui io sono nata e cresciuta e
tra i
due si sarebbe trasferita proprio
lei
già e
adesso era questa la domanda che mi
ponevo senza riuscire a darmi una
risposta sola 19 anni senza un lavoro né
tantom meno una base economica che cosa
avrei potuto fare dove sarei potuta
andare attraversa hai un vero e proprio
momento di crisi
però decisi che la vita doveva andare
avanti Quindi provai a fare qualcosa che
non avevo mai fatto prima provai a
cambiare atteggiamento a guardare Il
rovescio della
medaglia certo non fu un processo facile
né tantomeno immediato figuriamoci però
alla fine Ci riuscì così tanto bene che
nel giro di qualche settimana avendo
cambiato il filtro con il quale guardavo
la situazione quella che all'inizio mi
sembrava un'enorme ingiustizia una
catastrofe universale Beh Si trasformò
nella mia più grande fortuna un
trampolino di lancio una vera e propria
occasione che finalmente mi avrebbe
permesso di realizzare quel sogno che da
così tanto tempo tenevo chiuso in un
cassetto ma che per un motivo o per
l'altro non riuscivo proprio a
realizzare ovviamente non avevo la più
pallida idea di come avrei fatto ma ero
determinata a
scoprirlo cavalcando l'onda di questo
ottimismo nell'estate del 2012 conclusi
Finalmente il liceo ero
libera presi le mie cose feci lo zaino
Presi i risparmi che avevo faticosamente
messo da parte durante le stagioni nella
Riviera Romagnola e comprai il mio
primissimo biglietto di sol andata per
fare il giro del mondo e poi da quel
momento non mi sono più fermata Europa
Asia Africa America Oceania un'abbuffata
incredibile di Sapori e odori che
entrarono uno dopo l'altro dentro di me
cambiandoli nel profondo perché è
proprio questo che fa il viaggio vi
rivoluziona da dentro portandovi a
scoprire lati di voi che Altrimenti non
potreste mai
immaginare chi sono cosa voglio cosa mi
rende
felice Ecco le domande che porsi a me
stessa durante le mie prime avventure
arrivando a comprendere che io volevo
continuare a vivere la mia vita
viaggiando senza però precludermi
l'opportunità di studiare così Feci
qualche ricerca e mi trasferì in Francia
un luogo con un sistema universitario
accessibile ed economico dove sarebbe
stato più facile realizzare il mio
obiettivo ero all'università e cadde
qualcosa che non scorderò mai una
mattina arrivò una mia compagna e iniziò
a sistemarsi proprio accanto a me allora
io mi girai e nel farlo mi cadde
l'occhio nella sua Bors dove vidi la
copertina di un libro che catturò la mia
attenzione pensate era la straordinaria
storia di una ragazza che nel
1997 aveva attraversato a piedi tutto il
deserto
australiano partendo da Alice Spring
fino ad arrivare all'oceano indiano con
la sola compagnia di quattro cammelli e
un
cane Inutile dirvi che me ne innamorai e
questo fece nascere in me il grande
desiderio di replicare impresa
ovviamente a modo
mio così mi iscrissi ad un bando nella
speranza di riuscire a vincere un
concorso che mi avrebbe fatto
frequentare l'ultimo anno degli studi in
Canada lo vinsi e a quel punto non mi
rimaneva che un solo step Andai
all'università e mi recai nell'ufficio
della responsabile degli scambi
internazionali avevo il cuore in gola
perché sapevo che se lei non mi avesse
approvato il mio progetto non avesse
firmato i documenti io in Canada non ci
sarei mai andata
Ma ancor più sapevo che sarei andata
contro le sue idee contro il pensiero di
un sistema non ancora pronto all'idea
che una ragazza potesse sfidare regole
di buon costume e compiere missioni
impossibili presi coraggio mi presentai
alle di i miei documenti alch lei Mi
guardò e disse mancano i biglietti aerei
io non te li firmo Certo che mancavano i
bigliettii faceva parte del mio piano
così la Guardai e le dissi non c'è né il
biglietto di andata né quello di ritorno
perché io in Canada voglio arrivarci in
maniera alternativa a modo
mioe da Parigi e atterrare a Cancun una
volta in Messico voglio attraversare
tutto il paese e arrivare negli Stati
Uniti da San Diego voglio prendere tutta
la Rot 66 e nel giro di qualche
settimana voglio arrivare in Canada a
destinazione pronta per iniziare gli
studi sono 10.000 km e voglio farlo
tutto in autostop al che lei Mi guardò e
si mise a ridere pensando che stessi
scherzando o che fossi matta Come darle
torto avevo poco più di 20 anni ero
timida in esperta ma l'appena parlavo
l'inglese
figuriamoci Ma io Ero seria e quando lei
se ne rese conto cambiò totalmente
espressione poi cercò di dissuadermi in
ogni maniera possibile sei una donna non
puoi farlo è un'impresa impossibile devi
rinunciare me l'aveva detto così tante
volte che alla fine avevo quasi finito
per crederci ma non ho
mollato nei giorni successivi sono
tornata da lei finché non mi ha firmato
quei Benedetti documenti poi contro ogni
aspettativa sono partita organizzando la
mia avventura nella maniera più
economica possibile perché di soldi non
ne avevo sulla base di questa idea mi
sono adattata a tutto ho mangiato cibi
improbabili dormito in posti assurdi il
parrucchiere lo shopping manco a
pensarci ma soprattutto mi sono fatta
aiutare e ospitare da persone locali
senza farmi frenare da paure o
pregiudizi e questa sono io il giorno in
cui dopo 4 mesi di viaggio Finalmente
sono arrivata in quella che sarebbe
stata la mia nuova università in Canada
dove trascorsi l'anno più incredibile di
tutta la mia vita e ho scelto di farvi
vedere proprio questa foto perché
rappresenta uno dei momenti più
importanti più potenti di tutta la mia
vita perché in questo momento per la
prima volta mi sono fermata e mi sono
resa conto che avevo fatto qualcosa che
agli occhi di tutti ma anche ai miei Era
considerato impossibile già in
partenza Quindi Avevo acquisito più
consapevolezza nelle mie potenzialità e
avevo capito Mi ero aperta l'idea che
nulla fosse impossibile tantomeno per
una
ragazza da quel giorno ad oggi sono
passati più di 10
anni oggi sono una Nova digitale ho
visitato più di 60 paesi e l'ho fatto
prevalentemente in autostop completando
ben quattro volte il giro del
mondo e Se pensate che sia stato facile
non lo
è ci sono stati tanti momenti in cui ho
avuto paura momenti in cui non mi sono
sentita all'altezza momenti in cui ho
pensato di non
farcela la la prima volta che ho fatto a
stopo
pianto quando sono arrivata in Colombia
me la sono fatta addosso dall'ansia in
Australia ho fatto la lavapiatti la
donna delle pulizie affrontando ogni
sfida con
successo ma la cosa assurda Sapete qual
è È che se qualcuno me l'avesse detto
all'età di 18 anni quando ancora non
avevo messo il naso fuori dalla mia
cameretta sicuramente gli avrei riso in
faccia e poi me ne sarei anche
andata all'epoca avevo pensieri
limitanti No non sapevo che cosa Di che
cosa ero capace ma non è questa la cosa
su cui voglio farvi riflettere quello su
cui voglio porre l'accento è il fatto
che ogni volta che ho mosso un passo per
raggiungere un mio sogno qualcuno era lì
pronto per dirmi che sarebbe stato
impossibile prima mia madre Poi gli
amici e figuriamoci la società perché al
giorno d'oggi va così no pensare in
grande in maniera alternativa sfugge
alle regole della società perché questo
implica una grande espressione di sé una
forma di coraggio non
convenzionale Ma la società in cui
viviamo noi non premia il
coraggio preferisce che sia la paura
descrivere la quotidianità la paura di
sbagliare la paura di fallire la paura
di essere diversi e quindi abbiamo
sempre costantemente quell'impressione
di dover fare tutto da soli il che
sembra impossibile ma non lo è L'ho
capito quando mi sono buttata e uno dopo
l'altro ho realizzato tutti i sogni che
tenevo chiusi in un cassetto arrivando a
dei traguardi che non avrei mai
immaginato come fare il giro del mondo
essere qui davanti a voi a parlarvi
io una persona come tante
altre quindi a questo punto mi nasce
spontanea una
riflessione che cosa possiamo fare nella
quotidianità tutti è compresa Per
accrescere la stima che abbiamo in noi
stessi e imparare a sfruttare al massimo
il potere della nostra
mente Ecco io non ho la verità in tasca
e nemmeno pretendo di averla Ma se c'è
una cosa che ho capito durante i miei 11
anni di viaggi e avventure in tutto il
mondo è che uscire dalla propria zona di
comfort e lasciare che ogni piccola
conquista costruisca la nostra autostima
è già un grandissimo punto di
partenza questo perché la fiducia che
acquisiamo in noi stessi affrontando i
nostri limiti cambia la percezione che
abbiamo in noi stessi e di conseguenza
cambiano anche i nostri pensieri e poi è
più facile affrontare quei momenti in
cui il gioco si fa duro ma noi vogliamo
portare comunque a casa la vittoria Io
cerco sempre di farlo e questo è
quell'atteggiamento mentale che mi ha
permesso di lanciarmi in tantissime
avventure anche se magari ne Ero
terrorizzata e ognuna di queste mi ha
insegnato qualcosa di
straordinario ma l'insegnamento più
grande che io voglio condividere oggi
qui con voi è solo uno quello che nessun
sogno è poi così grande da non poter
essere realizzato ma siamo noi i primi a
doverci credere perché nessuno lo farà
mai al nostro posto figuriamoci e lo
aveva capito bene anche Jessica Watson
che all'età di 16 anni ha compiuto Il
giro del mondo in barcavela da sola Alex
honold che ha compiuto l'impresa
dell'arrampicata moderna più
straordinaria di tutte scalando a mani
nude una roccia di 900 m
Ma perché vi sto dicendo tutto
questo perché a un certo punto dei miei
viaggi delle mie grandi avventure ho
voluto tirare le
somme ho pensato al mio percorso dove
ero partita dove' ero arrivata che cosa
avevo fatto Mi sono confrontata con
persone che avevano una vita e una
filosofia diversa dalla mia e ho
confrontato la mia vita con quella di
tutte le persone che in qualche modo mi
avevano
ispirata e allora ho capito che nella
vita c'è una e una sola cosa che fa
davvero la
differenza
fortuna
bellezza o forse il
destino quello che fa davvero la
differenza nella vita è l'approccio
mentale ossia il potere della mente il
fatto di credere credere davvero in
qualcosa con tutto il cuore il corpo e
la mente credere di essere felici anche
nei momenti più tristi credere di essere
in grado di fare qualsiasi cosa anche
quello che i cosiddetti espertoni
ritengono
impossibile Ora io non sono una
scienziata in Canada ho studiato
psia Ma se c'è una cosa che ho ben
chiara è che il genio non vive nella
genetica Ma nella
mente non pensate di do essere Wonder
Woman Superman o dei geni per do fare
cose nella vita questo perché il talento
da solo non basta trascendere
l'ordinario quell che ha funzionato per
me per altre persone probabilmente anche
per molti tra voi è un mix di
fattori fra cui laione la costanza la
perseveranza Ma alla base di tutto ci
sta il giusto
atteggiamento Life is a State of Mind la
vita è uno stato mentale e quando
capiamo che siamo gli unici e soli
artefici della realtà che ci circonda
Beh allora Tutto cambia in quel momento
la vita come per miracolo può diventare
un paradiso e tutte le cose accadono
oggi qui davanti a voi io Voglio
augurarvi proprio
questo Voglio augurarvi di imparare a
sfruttare al massimo il potere della
vostra mente di credere
nell'impossibile di non lasciarvi mai
abbattere dalla paura perché avere paura
è normale Io l'ho avuta sempre ma questa
non deve essere un
blocco Inoltre Voglio augurarvi di
tenere sempre presente chi siete e di
che cosa siete capaci ogni singolo
giorno della vostra vita in modo da
alzarvi con la giusta carica inseguire i
vostri sogni e
realizzarli mi chiamo Linda Linda
Campostrini e sono una ragazza qualsiasi
capace di qualsiasi
cosa e Voi chi siete voi e di che cosa
siete
capaci
Grazie
i